hélène la saillie responsable du
département des délégations régionales
de li na li na est présent en région au
travers de six délégations régionales
qui sont implantées sur l'ensemble dû
territoire métropolitain plus la corse
nous sommes présents à lille à
strasbourg à lyon à marseille à toulouse
et à rennes
tessi délégation couvre donc un certain
nombre de régions administratives et le
découpage de chaque région confié à
chaque délégation colle avec bien
évidemment le découpage des régions
administratives françaises dans chaque
délégation nous avons une équipe de
quatre personnes qui couvre 4 le
territoire dont ils ont la charge par le
responsable de région est ce qu'on
appelle un délégué régional qui
travaille avec un responsable
documentaire un responsable technique et
une assistante qui fait aussi fonction
d'attaché commercial
historiquement les régions c'est
beaucoup collecter archives et les fonds
de l'usaid public de radio france et
france télévisions maintenant que le psn
a pris fin on s'est positionné depuis
déjà un moment mais on renforce le
positionnement de valoriser et
d'éditorialiser au plus près des clients
en région
l'ensemble des collections régionales on
m'a demandé la télévision de bien
vouloir paraît mais ce soir la première
émission de provence actualitté vous
pensez que je ne pouvais pas refuser
on travaille beaucoup avec les
collectivités territoriales que ce soit
des municipalités des communautés de
communes des départements des régions
aussi beaucoup les conseils régionaux
aime beaucoup à nous rencontrer et
élaborer des projets avec nous on
travaille bien évidemment avec tous les
acteurs du monde de la culture donc ça
peut être des musées des festivals est
également bien évidemment avec tout ce
qui relève du dépôt légal c'est-à-dire
travail avec les universités et au delà
des universités les écoles et
médiathèques des cinémas d'art et
d'essai où on organise des projections
tout ce qui compose en fait la vie
autour des médias et de la culture dans
toutes les régions françaises avec les
collectivités territoriales nous avons
développé déjà depuis plusieurs années
des productions web ou des objets
multimédias qu'on appelle souvent des
fresques multimédia qui sont mis en
ligne ensuite à la fois sur le site de
la région du département et sur le site
de l'ina ou ça rassemble des documents
de l'ina et ça raconte soit une
personnalité soit une ville soit une
région et s'est réalisé
en lien avec le studio hypermédia du
département des éditions numériques